[Music]
hello Jessica Jones you are cheater you
were given every advantage allowed to
make mistake after mistake you can't
control yourself you have known
discipline just brute force what do you
want I want you to die
Gregory Salinger you smarter than both
of us combined analogues with that I
know you are it's not exactly a secret
so you know I can break your face I
barely survived him Salinger did this
let's go get him I don't need your help
and you don't need mine
he was unjustly arrested when you cozia
two maniacs people around you get hurt
[Music]
everybody's got a story a beginning a
middle and end
I'm late for work as what super cat
burglar
you don't want Jess you do it your way
I'm gonna do it my way
they're still away this ends with me
respecting you it's not my highest
priority right now
Jessica Jones you believe you could save
the world
terrified you've already failed and you
have because you are armed and you never
a hero
[Music]
he's still a hero if nobody thinks you
are like I give a [ __ ] what other people
think
[Music]